[Music]
when grass was buried
wake up here and say goodbye to your
father who's the homeless person on the
cabbage this is why I love coming home
for Christmas
right before you leave town be nice dear
he's been studying abroad really which
broad what's her name
Candice give me a favor try not to burn
the house down before Monday okay so
it's Monday that is good to know I won't
plan my toga party accordingly where you
going
your father's flying us to the Bahamas
for a little getaway we might have to
make a quick stop at the Pentagon right
don't worry you're gonna love the
holiday menu at the commissary you know
they say sarcasm is a metric for
potential if that's true you'll be a
great man someday I'll get the bags he
does miss you and you're not here and
frankly you're going to miss us because
this is the last time we're all going to
be together you know what's about to
happen say something if you don't you'll
regret it
I love you den and I know you did the
best you could
that's how I wish it happen
by nearly augmented retro framing or
barf God I got to work on that acronym
an extremely costly method of hijacking
the hippocampus to clear traumatic
memories it doesn't change the fact that
they never made it to the airport or all
the things I did to avoid processing my
grief plus 611 million dollars for my
little therapeutic experiment no one in
their right mind would have ever funded
it helped me out what's the MIT mission
statement to generate disseminate and
preserve knowledge and work with others
to bring it to bear on the world's great
challenges yeah well you are the others
and quite as it's kept challenges facing
you are the greatest men kinds of an own
plus most of your broke officer I'd
rather you were as of this moment every
student has been made an equal recipient
of the inaugural September foundation
grant as in all of your projects have
just been approved and funded
[Applause]
we frame the future starting now
[Applause]
go perk snakes
you
you